[Music]
on this Thursday night motivated by hate
police investigate a stabbing at an
Ontario University that allegedly
targeted a gender studies class
investigators have reason to believe
that this was a planned and targeted
attack what we know about the suspects
and his victims
air quality alerts more suffocating
smoke fueled by Canada's worst wildfires
Smothers cities on both sides of the
Border we can barely see the capital
plus the battle to rebuild why aren't
these folks getting some service two
years since the village of Linton BC
burned to the ground arnithu Garcia
returns to find the community dealing
with loss and lawsuits access denied
Google's plan to block Canadian news
after Ottawa tries to Force tech Giants
to pay up you can always find things
that you can use as
what the hell are you talking about plus
The Life and Legacy of beloved Canadian
broadcaster and trailblazing sex
educator Sue Johansen
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Jeff Semple good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin tonight with what police are
calling an attack motivated by hate a
professor and two students were stabbed
in their classroom at the University of
Waterloo investigators say the class was
targeted because its subject was gender
issues
this incident is a tragic reminder
during pride month that as we celebrate
our progress the safety and well-being
of some in our community is still in
question
prime minister Justin Trudeau called the
attack horrifying and unacceptable
a 24 year old former student is now
facing multiple charges Eric Sorensen is
in Waterloo with more on the suspect and
his alleged motive
and I'm still a bit of shock and also
I'm just feeling a bit angry and it says
James Chao he was scared for his life
when a young man entered his classroom
asked what the class was about and when
asked to leave by the gender studies
Professor he attacked he raised the
knife and started chasing the professor
I grabbed a chair right was as he
cornered the professor in the back of
the room and threw a chair at him the
and when I threw the chair I remember
seeing the professor was like on the
ground covering her face and screaming a
horrific scene as 40 students screamed
and fled the classroom police were on
the scene within minutes the suspect
tried to blend in with other students
but was identified and apprehended the
professor and two students sustained
non-life-threatening injuries in the
attack the gender studies class was no
coincidence say police it was a crime of
hate investigators have reason to
believe that this was a planned and
targeted attack motivated by hate
related to gender expression and gender
identity this suspect is 24 year old
international student Giovanni villalba
Elman he's been charged with three
counts of aggravated assault plus
weapons charges I didn't really believe
it initially and then I saw my phone as
on emails pranav Shireen has classes in
hege Hall every day our community is so
safe right I never saw that something
happened like this throughout the
university shock and dismay that a
peaceful day on campus turned horribly
violent I know that we didn't receive
like any notification from the school at
the time there was a very unfortunate
delay the university admits its
emergency response system which was just
tested that morning did not kick in
quickly enough to alert The Wider campus
the attack occurred during pride month a
time that promotes inclusiveness and
celebrates the lgbtq2 plus Community
while this is shocking and horrific act
it must be denounced we must make it
exceptionally clear that hate or
Prejudice in any form is unacceptable
late in the day a rally was held in
Waterloo to stand up for a community
that once again has been targeted while
simply seeking acceptance the accused
has been remanded in custody and there
will be a bail hearing next week several
students told us they were shaken by
what happened but they believed that it
was an isolated incident and that the
University of Waterloo campus remains a
safe place Jeff Eric Sorensen in
Waterloo Ontario tonight thanks Eric
much of Southern Ontario is breathing
easier today as that Wildfire smoke that
blanketed the region began to clear but
alerts remain in place for Millions
South of the Border
we can barely see the capital so it's
just it's weird
Washington DC was home to the world's
worst air quality at one point today as
smoke from hundreds of Canadian
wildfires drifted over the Northeastern
United States more than 20 states were
placed under some form of air quality
alert in the South Millions more are
dealing with a deadly heat Dome with
temperatures in several States expected
to Top 40 degrees
and it was two years ago this week that
another deadly heat Dome shattered
records in Canada and led to one of the
worst Wildfire disasters this country
has ever seen three straight days of
record heat help to fuel a fire that
destroyed hundreds of properties in
Linton BC that Community was reduced to
Ash and since then efforts to rebuild
have hit a wall
arnuthugarcha has been speaking with
residents who remain in Latin nithu
Jeff the nearly two-year local state of
emergency lifted last week but the
rebuilding hasn't even begun the mayor
says not a single building permit has
been issued
for anyone passing by it's hard to tell
there was a village here we haven't
started rebuilding yet it's it's just
unbelievable and hard to imagine Denise
O'Connor who was born and raised here
and lost her home in the fire says the
first phase of recovery including
remediation and archaeological reports
is almost done this was my home yeah we
lived here for
30 something years the next phase
includes installing utilities and
services it has seemed and maybe it
still seems that Linton has really been
forgotten or swept under a rug Megan
vanderich's home is among the few that
didn't burn but living here has been
difficult to get a jug of milk from my
daughter I would have to drive at least
an hour on a bad road but it was just
lush green forest the single mother
looks down to where her business once
stood a beloved coffee shop destroyed
there needs to be some sort of
accountability The Village's insurance
provider has now filed a claim against
Canada's two national Railways CN and CP
as well as Transport Canada freight
trains are a common sight in Linton
according to the court filing a coal
train had just passed through the
village less than 20 minutes before the
first report of a fire near these tracks
the claim alleges they were negligent to
let trains pass through the town during
an unprecedented Heat Wave and extreme
Wildfire risk the store the fire ravaged
90 percent of the town's buildings two
people were killed and several others
were injured none of the allegations
have been proven in court and the
Transportation safety board says it
completed its investigation without
interviewing residents most of the work
I've been doing is with the indigenous
Community Bruce Ramsey is a certified
traumatologist in the Greater Vancouver
area he also works with Litton First
Nation basically the village still does
not exist I was shocked and I was angry
and I and I was a little embarrassed
actually to be a tax paying person in
the province of BC like why aren't these
folks getting some service I think
there's going to be huge Lessons Learned
on how to do things differently O'Connor
says especially with so many other
communities across Canada already under
threat from wildfires it's important for
everyone that Linton residents get
answers and accountability and action
the TSB says it found no evidence
linking the fire to nearby train
activity and a report released in 2022
there is an ongoing investigation by the
BC Wildfire service and the RCMP
residents waiting for answers say
without an official cause of the
devastating fire it's hard to find
closure Jeff you through garcha in
Litton BC thanks Nita Google says it's
pulling the plug on Canadian news
content it plans to remove links to news
sites on all Platforms in this country
the move follows a similar announcement
from Facebook over the federal
government's new law that forces Tech
Giants to pay up Mackenzie gray reports
on ottawa's Cyber standoff
it's the latest blow to the prime
minister's plan to force big tack to cut
deals with media publishers for sharing
and directing users to online news
content Google blocking Canadian users
from Canadian news bill c18 has become
law and Remains unworkable the tech
Giants said we've been saying for over a
year that this is the wrong approach to
supporting journalism in Canada well I
think this definitely is a really Brazen
admission that Google and to another
extent Facebook really don't give a fake
about news in Canada Google's move
surprising the minister responsible we
spoke to them this morning my chief of
staff spoke to them I met with them last
week the feds had hoped to use this
legislation to help the struggling media
industry which has lost millions in ad
Revenue to the big Tech platforms all
while thousands of journalists have been
laid off Global News is among Canadian
media organizations which already has a
partnership with Google which pays to
share news content Google pulling out of
Canadian news could have even more
damaging consequences unfortunately this
means a huge drop in revenue for for
many journalist organizations
particularly smaller ones who tend to
depend the most on social shares
Facebook had already announced they
would drop Canadian news and they
increased the pressure today canceling a
fellowship program that supports the
hiring of emerging journalists at the
Canadian press a senior government
Source had written off coming to a deal
with meta but had expressed optimism and
agreement with Google could be made and
that same Source says the Liberals have
no plans to back down on their new law
saving the stage for a major political
divide Justin Trudeau has tried to shut
down competition by passing censorship
laws Google said they pull out of
Canadian news before the final
regulations come into Force that's
expected to take six months leaving time
Jeff for a deal to be made with the
Liberals
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks Mac
Financial experts are sounding the alarm
about Canadians ability to deal with
their debt Canada's household debt is
now the highest of any G7 nation and
with higher interest rates new data
shows more people are turning to their
credit cards to pay the bills and
gaviola has more on our credit conundrum
the cost of just about everything
continues to climb
food to rent to mortgages a lot of of
these are are putting a real burden on
people's pocketbook pushing more of us
to use credit cards just to get by if
you don't have the money as I said if
you don't have the money readily
available
um the easy decision in the moment is is
to just put it on your your credit card
though it just ends up creating a really
vicious cycle recent data shows plastic
Reliance by businesses and households is
on the rise according to Consumer Credit
Reporting Agency Equifax spending on
credit cards is up more than 21 percent
compared to before the pandemic people
that are using this these credit cards
more are ones that pay less than 90
percent of their credit card off every
month insolvency experts say that and
more people turning to ultra high
interest payday style loans many with
annual interest rates over 400 percent
plus fees can all lead to a lifetime of
financial hardship so people will be
saddled with this debt you know
potentially for the rest of a working
career if they don't pay down more of
the principal interest rates in the 20
percent range on credit card debt can
quickly snowball now you're having to
come up with that much more that you
didn't have in your bank account to
begin with which means you end up
financing more and then you just keep
going further and further down that
rabbit hole if
money is coming in and how much you're
spending step two if needed find
professional help some people literally
have to change their lifestyle and and
buy less don't buy luxury items just buy
Essentials buy cheaper where they can
for every dollar the average Canadian
household earns it owes a dollar and 85
cents for many cutting back can go a
long way towards ensuring this is a
financial rough patch and not the path
to a debt trap and gaviola Global News
Toronto
Roseanne Archibald is out
coming up why the Assembly of First
Nations National Chief was impeached
[Music]
there's a major shakeup at the Assembly
of First Nations afn Chiefs voted to
fire their national leader Roseanne
Archibald she was elected in 2021
becoming the first woman to hold the
post but as David Aiken reports an
investigation found she violated the
organization's code of conduct
goodness and love Roseanne Archibald
made history in 2021 when she won the
top job at the Assembly of First Nations
the first woman to be the national Chief
elected with a mandate to shake things
up voices are being heard
that were never heard before but she
makes history as she leaves that top job
the first national Chief man or woman to
be removed before the end of her
three-year term I support the national
Chief when she ran through the election
but
it was just time to move on assimilation
and genocide the Assembly of First
Nations is the country's largest
indigenous advocacy group its National
Chief is selected by majority votes of
the country's 634 First Nations Chiefs
on Wednesday just 231 of those Chiefs
had a day-long zoom call and then 163 of
them were 71 percent voted in favor of
removing her Archibald's Defenders
believe her gender played a role that
the Chiefs would never have voted a man
out of the job but Archibald could not
overcome the findings of a third party
investigator that found she abused her
staff and violated the assembly's code
of conduct we have to keep everybody
accountable regardless what part of the
staff of the afn you are in if you're in
the top part or if you're administrative
you know we're all equal in in that that
opposite there were just too much
damages right now and we just need some
healing and time for this healing now
needed after one of the most divisive
episodes in the organization's history
Jeff
thanks David David Aiken in Ottawa
and for more on the Fallout from this
impeachment let's go straight to our
Melissa region in Winnipeg hi Melissa so
what's been the reaction from Grassroots
members and what do you think this means
for the future of the afn
while Jeff reaction has been largely
head shaking and eye rolls you know the
first the Assembly of First Nations
deals with the government of Canada as a
lobbyist for First Nations issues the
criticism criticism has always been that
it doesn't represent what people want or
what they expect they have no say in
what happens at the afn it's only Chiefs
that have a seat at that table so
Archibald campaigned on change she
campaigned on accountability including
on things like spending and putting the
brakes on perceived entitlements in the
organization how she went about it how
she treated some folks it looks like
that that was problematic and perhaps
worthy of some sanctions or some
discipline of some sort but some are
saying that she was removed before she
could accomplish what it was she was
elected to do the questions that she
asked are crucial and we will now never
have the answers for because what will
happen now is the regional Chiefs will
now appoint someone who will be
favorable to their interests
and that's what will happen next an
interim National Chief will be selected
until another election can be held at
the end of this year all right Melissa
Ridge in Winnipeg thanks
riots and unrest still ahead protesters
in France clash with police over the
deadly shooting of a teenager
foreign
Devastation in central Chile after an
overflowing river triggered a landslide
at least two people are dead and four
are missing after multiple communities
flooded during heavy rains the Army is
now working to move mud and debris off
the streets it's estimated nearly 14 000
people are affected by the flooding
there was another day of protests in
France over the death of a teenager shot
by police during a traffic stop
police fire tear gas into the crowd
where thousands turned out to march in
memory of the 17 year old Redmond
Shannon now on the growing outrage and
the charge against the officer involved
thousands join a mother's screaming for
justice over the death of her only child
in the two days since the police killing
of the 17 year old publicly known only
as nael France has seen unrest and
rioting spread
starting in the Paris suburb of
non-terror where he lived and died
Thursday's March also turned into chaos
police the target of the anger they are
trying to quell the video of the
shooting during a Tuesday morning
traffic stop the spark for that Fury the
officer who fired the shot now under
arrest and charged with voluntary
homicide French president Emmanuel
macron initially called the shooting
inexcusable
Now using similar language to refer to
the violent protests that targeted
parked cars and public buildings
including schools the government has
deployed 40 000 police officers to the
streets
their fear is that this could spiral
further and mirror the type of rioting
scene across France in 2005 that unrest
born out of the disaffection and racism
experienced by immigrant and minority
communities in the suburbs of Paris and
major cities
many of those protesting and rioting now
feel little has changed since then a
period of time almost exactly matching
Nails life Redmond Shannon Global News
London
it would get very hot in there I would
say you better believe it
[Music]
up next remembering beloved Canadian sex
educator Sue Johansen
for generations of Canadians she was
known for her straight talk on taboo
topics Sue Johansen a celebrated
educator who spoke about sex with an
uncommon frankness and honesty has died
at the age of 93. Heather York's West
looks at her Legacy and why her message
remains relevant today
I was told that the first thing you want
to do is dispel some common myths men
are convinced that to be a good lover
they've got to have this humongous as a
sex educator Sue Johansen had no fear
strike matches on it
by the early 2000s her celebrity as the
granny who'd answer all your intimate
questions had spread to Hollywood but
for decades Sue Johansen was Canada's
own condoms
they'll do the trick educating young
people over the airwaves long before it
was possible to do a Google search she
had that very deep voice and I remember
being at the time kind of shocked like
oh my gosh she's talking about that
after navigating her own teenage years
without a mother Johansson opened
Canada's first birth control clinic
inside a high school when her own
daughter was still a student there I'm
so proud of who she was and what she did
with her call in radio show launched in
1984 and a TV show later on Johansson
helped young people learn about sex as
the world came to grips with AIDS mom
was fearless and made no bones about
having
a lot of AIDS patients from Casey House
come up to her Cottage every summer
although she slowed down in her 80s
Johansson never truly retired pained in
recent years to see so much progress
made for women's sexual health Health
appear to take steps back especially
about abortion in the states that I
remember once she reacted by just
shutting her eyes shaking her head and
and turning her head away
just like I can't fix this but because
of her Legacy a new generation of
Educators have stepped in to take her
place I was never seen as a sex kitten I
had the gift of the gab life lessons
from a tough talking granny millions of
Canadians will never forget Heather your
ex-west Global News Calgary
thanks Sue and that is global national
for this Thursday I'm Jeff Semple
tonight's your Canada is this Beaver
chilling in the South Saskatchewan River
thanks for watching have a great night
hahaha
[Music]